>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> David H. Plylar: Good
afternoon/early evening.
It's so great to have you all here.
I don't know if did any of
you catch the performance
in the afternoon already?
Or are you here in anticipation
of tonight's performance?
>> Aaron Sherber: Or
both performances?
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
Yeah. Oh, good.
My name is David Plylar and I'm
a music specialist at the Library
of Congress and I'm here with two
special guests just to talk about--
a bit about the history
of composing for dance
at the Library of Congress.
But also, to talk about what
is involved in that process
of composing for dance, and
actually putting together a project
like the one that we're all
being able to take part of,
which is what the Martha Graham
Dance Company this weekend
and actually over the past
week, which is involved--
talks about Isamu Noguchi as well
as some other aspects
of the Graham legacy.
So, I'm pleased to have with me
Aaron Sherber, who is the conductor
and music director
for these performances
and with the Martha
Graham Dance Company.
And he's been leading the way with
our musicians and you won't see him
but he's in the pit
doing all the work.
So, you know, with the musicians.
And so, he offers a
very unique perceptive
that we'll be able to get.
And then also, Libby Smigel who is
our new dance archivist curator.
We're not sure we just
call her the dance person.
And she's been a delight to
have in the music division
and will offer some
perspective from that side.
So, before we get started,
what I thought we could do is maybe
just give a little bit of background
on who you are, that
would be helpful.
>> Libby Smigel: I come from
traipse and through a lot
of different aspects of dance
and I realized I did work
with a composer back in my
undergrad days, which are hard
to remember at this point.
Where I was choreographing for a
production in Greek of "The Bacchae"
and doing that for my senior
theses and working with the person
in the music division, who is
doing her own senior theses
and was writing for the
dancing at the same time,
and it didn't ruin our friendship.
So, there was that.
And then, I have also
gotten a PhD in drama.
So, I am bringing that to the floor
and my most recent work before
coming to the library in August,
I headed the Dance Heritage
Coalition, which was an association
of dance archives and
museums and libraries
so that we will be saving better,
we hope, dance legacies for all.
>> Aaron Sherber: I've been
with the Martha Graham Company
for almost 18 years, 1998 I started.
And actually, my first performance
with the company was here
at the library and it was the
first time that we brought back
"Appalachian Spring"
since the premier.
So, it was-- that was
quite something to step
into as my entre into that world.
I had no dance experience
as a conductor before that
but it gotten plenty
in the year since.
And along the way, one
of the interesting things
about my job has been-- because of
the way the Graham Company is setup,
I'm essentially the
whole music department.
So, it's part conductor, part
librarian, part archivist,
part historian and it's been
just a real thrill for me to come
into contact with these pieces
and find out what their history is
and how all these things
come together.
And it's also nice to be
back here at the Library.
>> David H. Plylar: Well,
it's great to have you.
And also, we'll talk
about this later perhaps
where you're doing
some editorial work--
>> Aaron Sherber: Yeah.
Uh-huh.
>> David H. Plylar: -- as well.
So, on some of these pieces.
So maybe we'll start with hearing
just a sentimental recording.
>> Which much affection,
Mrs. Coolidge.
>> Do you remember
Elizabeth Sprague Coolidge?
>> I certainly do and
with much affection.
Mrs. Coolidge really made her
mark, I think, on American music.
In the consistent way over the
years, she established and continued
to have here in Washington of
excellent chamber music concerts.
We really owe her a great debt
and I'm very glad you've
given me the opportunity
to say that in public.
I've often thought it and I wish
we had more Mrs. Coolidges around.
>> That relationship is sort of
symbiotic in a way because just as,
we, yourself, among the many
composers, owe a debt to her,
I think, her memory owes quite
a debt to the man who composed
"Appalachian Spring" for her.
[ Applause ]
>> You're forgetting Martha
Graham who created the work.
>> And it didn't even
have a title, did it?
>> No, it didn't.
I can't imagine that
being true any longer.
I'm so used to thinking of
it as "Appalachian Spring".
It never occurred to me
that when I was writing it,
I didn't know what
she would call it.
She hadn't given a name yet.
So after finishing the work
and reading it back to her
when she already had it in rehearsal
the first time I said her--
saw her, I said, "Martha, what
have you call the ballet?"
I called it ballet for Martha
just so, you know, in my own mind.
>> And that too-- That's exactly
what it says on the front page
of the manuscript,
ballet for Martha.
>> But that was the subtitle.
No, I didn't have a title.
I was really putting
Martha Graham to music.
I'd seen her dancing so many times.
I had a sense of her
personality as a creative artist.
I had a, really, in the front
of my mind, I wasn't thinking
about the Appalachians
or even spring.
So, that I had no title for it.
The first thing I said to her when
I came down to the rehearsal here
in Washington was, "Martha,
what did you call the ballet?"
She said, "Appalachian Spring."
Oh I said, "What a nice name.
Where did you get it?"
[ Laughter ]
She said, "Well, it's a title
of a poem by Hart Crane."
"Oh," I said, "Does the poem have
anything to do with the ballet?"
She said, "No.
I just like the title
and I took it."
[ Laughter ]
And over and over again,
nowadays, people come up to me
after seeing the ballet on
stage and say, "Mr. Copland,
when I see that ballet and
when I hear your music,
I can just see the
Appalachians and feel the spring."
[ Laughing ]
I began to see the
Appalachian myself a little bit.
[ Laughter ]
>> Aaron Sherber: I have to add
two quick things about that.
First of all, Copland
loved telling that story
and he told it almost
verbatim multiple times
and I haven't heard the one
with the laugh track like that.
So that's a new one.
But the second interesting thing
that I think even Copland either
may not be aware of or glossed over,
it's not spring the season, it's
spring a body of water in the poem.
And very few people
are aware of that.
>> David H. Plylar: It's not--
If I'm not mistaken,
it's also not the title.
>> Aaron Sherber: I know, it's
also not the title, I believe.
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
It's--
>> Aaron Sherber: Yeah,
it's in there.
>> David H. Plylar:
I have a colleague,
a retired colleague
name Wayne Shirley
who put together this really nice
overview of the whole process
of commissioning "Appalachian
Spring" and also the other ballets
that were-- or works that were
included on this event in 1944,
that kind of goes into this in
great detail covering correspondence
and things like that.
So, he addresses that
at that at one point.
You know, as funny as it is,
it actually brings up a lot
of interesting issues that I think
are there from the onset of the--
at the beginning of
any great undertaking.
And I consider any great
undertaking one that requires more
than one person because you have
to come to terms with each other
in some way if you're going
to create some meaningful
work of art together.
And so, even something as seen
as kind of tangential or kind
of after the fact as the title
of the work, that is the way
that we have first access to
it in some-- in many ways.
So, it's-- it ended up people--
it has a certain resonance with
people today that, you know,
if it were-- if it had a terrible
title, it wouldn't have helped it,
you know, it's always nice that it
had this poetic component to it.
And one of the thing I just want to
mention about this and maybe, Aaron,
you may be able to speak to
this as well, is that he did say
that he didn't know what
Martha was going to call it.
That was the same, I think, the same
situation for the Hindemith work,
"Herodiade" and the Milhaud work
because they were--
had different titles.
>> Aaron Sherber: Well--
Though the Hindemith did not.
The Hindemith I believe--
what do you have?
You got something?
>> David H. Plylar:
"Mirror Before Me"?
>> Aaron Sherber: "Mirror
Before Me", oh you're right.
So, it was called "Herodiade"
ultimately because both Hindemith
and Graham based their work
on the Mellarme pros
and poem by that name--
>> David H. Plylar: Right.
>> Aaron Sherber: And I think it
just made more sense ultimately.
I'd forgotten "Mirror Before Me."
Yeah. But that, you
know, but the naming--
that's not unusual that
the name comes last.
>> David H. Plylar: Sure.
>> Aaron Sherber: And in
fact, the world premiere,
the Pontus Lidberg ballet didn't
have a name about 2 weeks ago
when they had to print
it in the program.
So, you know, that
fortuitous things.
And the Barber that
were performing "Cave
of the Heart" was originally called
"Serpent Heart" when
it was premiered.
Another Graham ballet "Diversion
of Angels" was originally called
"Wilderness Stair"
when it premiered.
So sometimes that process of
finding a name is, you know,
it's the act of summing up
what it is you've created
and sometimes it takes a little
while for that to settle in.
>> David H. Plylar:
Well, there's also that
and there's also what the
composer might call it on the side
versus what the completed
work is called.
So like in the case of Milhaud
who had a piece that was also--
and he called it "Jeux de
Printemps" I think and then--
but went by the name
of "Imagined Wing".
So, I think in his catalogue, he
kept it as with the French title
but it-- so there's
different-- it never quite--
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
And the Barber piece
is called "Medea".
>> David H. Plylar: Right.
>> Aaron Sherber: His-- The
published ballet is called "Medea".
On the other hand, I think
people do make a little too much
about the fact that Copland
titled it "Ballet for Martha"
because really, what else
was he going to call it?
If you're writing a piece of
music and you're writing a ballet
for Martha, you know,
that's what he put on.
I don't think he ever
intended that to be a title.
>> David H. Plylar: Sure, sure.
>> Aaron Sherber: But I know
in all the Graham programs
when we perform it, it always says
how Aaron Copland called it "Ballet
for Martha" which Martha changed
it "Appalachian Spring" and I--
at first, I think there's little
too much significance in that but--
>> David H. Plylar: Sure.
Sure.
>> Libby Smigel: Yeah.
And actually, "House of
Victory" was one of the titles
that Martha had settled
on in her iterations
of sending scenarios
to Aaron Copland.
And I think it's to his credit,
he didn't decide to adopt
that one right away, you know.
But she, you know, has
a handwritten, you know,
this is a working title and, you
know, I think it sort of still was
in the process of being created
and it makes a lot of sense not
to settle on something too soon.
>> David H. Plylar: Well, sure.
And you know, and before we even get
to this process of getting created,
you know, it's one thing
for friends to get together
and put together, you know, a work.
But it's another if you're talking
about professionals coming together
and working under contract and
having those types of issues
that one must think about especially
with these larger works and these--
the correspondence
and effort that goes
into just the business end
of putting it together.
I don't mean it in a crass
way, meaning like, it--
there is a cost to hire 12
performers versus 5 performers.
If you only have enough
money for five performers,
chances are the piece will
probably only have five players.
If you have-- there's other
considerations such as space,
for instance, the Coolidge
Auditorium, we--
most people know "Appalachian
Spring" and it's kind
of rich large orchestral version
but maybe don't know as much
about that original version.
And maybe Aaron, you
can say a little bit?
>> Aaron Sherber Yeah.
Also, I wanted to add there, there's
a funny letter that Wayne reproduces
in there from Erick
Hawkins who was--
it was the first husband when he was
the company manager at Martha Graham
at that time and also became
Martha's husband for a couple
of years, that's a
whole other story.
But he-- there's a letter
that Wayne reproduces in there
where Erick is complaining about
the fact the Hindemith decided
to add a second violin.
He said that could wreck
our touring budget.
>> David H. Plylar: It's true.
>> Aaron Sherber: Which
is-- Yeah, it is very true.
Yeah. That the various versions
of "Appalachian Spring"
are very difficult.
It's a very long and tangled story
and in fact, if you read just
about any biography of Aaron
Copland they get it wrong.
I mean, very bright people who spent
a lot of time studying Copland.
It's just-- It's very confusing.
So, Copland wrote the piece for
Martha Graham, it was premiered here
at Library, it was a ballet, it
was written for 13 instruments,
double string quartet plus base,
piano, flute, clarinet and bassoon.
The year after the ballet premiered,
Copland made a sweet
out of it for orchestra.
So, he took about 6 minutes out
of the "Simple Gifts" variation
and if you go nips and
tucks here and there
and scored it up for full orchestra.
And that's the way, I know
in my parents' generation,
that's what everybody knew
at the orchestra suite.
It was hugely popular in the '40s
and '50s and through the '60s
and even today, it's one of his
most often performed pieces.
There are a couple of reasons
why people are less familiar
with the 13 instrument version.
One is, while Martha was alive, she
died in 1991, Copland stipulated
that nobody but Martha could
play the ballet version.
And there's a funny story behind
that which is when she died
and Boosey & Hawkes who
was her publisher said,
"Great but not great.
But now we can rent this out
and make some money off of it."
They realized, they didn't even
have parts to it and they called
up the Graham Company and said, "I
know you have parts which you paid
for and made but technically,
they're our property,"
because they hold the copyright.
So they consider them
to be on permanent loan.
So they said, "Send us a set of your
part so we can make a copy of them."
And to this day, if you
rent the ballet from Boosey,
you get a really bad
Xerox of our parts
because they just--
So that's changing.
But Copland himself-- Copland
for a long time preferred
the orchestral version.
And if you listen to it,
I mean, it sounds a lot
like the other stuff he
was doing at that time.
It sounds like "Rodeo"
and "Billy the Kid".
It's very much of that time period
and the same use of the orchestra.
It wasn't until the late '60s that
some friends of his convinced him
that people wanted to hear at
least the chamber orchestration
that didn't had value of its own.
And so, in 1972, what he did
was he took the edits he made
to make the orchestral suite, he
made the same edits to the ballet
so that you now have
a 13-instrument suite.
So the same musical material
as the orchestral version
but the original orchestration.
And then, for a couple of decades,
a lot of people grew
up knowing it that way.
As a young conductor, we
all know the 13-instrument
"Appalachian Spring" suit
because it's on every audition.
When you're putting together
an audition tape to go
to graduate school, 13 players
is really easy to get together.
So every young conductor
in my day, you know,
grows up knowing that suite.
And in the ballet version,
hearing that extra music and some
of you heard this afternoon,
others will hear it tonight,
but there's about 6 minutes in
the middle of "Simple Gifts"
where you go, "Where
did that come from?
I have never heard
that music before.
Is that even Copland?"
But it gets very complicated because
there were other versions of things.
Copland orchestrated some but
not all of the missing music
in the 1950's and some
conductors like to put that--
put a big insert into the
suit and then some people
like to put the same insert
into the 13-instrument suit.
There's a version that
Boosey has been publishing
which they say is complete
which isn't really complete.
It's a long story, but we're in
the process of rectifying that
and maybe I'll get to that later.
>> David H. Plylar: Well, sure.
Well, in addition to these
issues that have to do
with instrumentation, there are
of course the production costs
and thoughts, you know,
that have to do
with the creation of
a large dance work.
And maybe Libby you can speak to
that alone or just about what types
of things people have to think
about when they're putting
together these things.
>> Libby Smigel: Well,
I think in think
in the initial even
conversations between the composer
and the choreographer
to find that place
of working together is essential.
And I am still in awe of some of
the ones, the examples we have
where they're carrying
this correspondence
on by mail across,
you know, an ocean.
And I think about in the
Library of Congress materials,
we have a collection of
correspondence between Ruth Page,
who is sort of a Ballet Russe
generation, Chicago dancers,
choreographer who is
really interested
in getting herself on the map.
It's a very interesting piece
in itself a small correspondence
with a composer named Remi Gassmann,
who was interested in working
with her, but this-- he was
living in Strasbourg at the time
when she was trying to
get this group together,
even getting a rehearsal
piano score,
she couldn't do to try this out.
And it seemed to end up being a
correspondence about composers
that can't meet deadlines,
which of course we have
with the Martha Graham as well
because we have the problem
with the "Dark Meadow".
And again, Carlos Chavez was in
Mexico busy being a conductor now
of a major symphony and even
though he had a great track record
of having composed just
myriad pieces, it just seemed
as though this wasn't going
come to the finish line.
And, you know, there is some
interesting correspondence
in the Spivak collection
at the Library of Congress
where finally he's
pulling the plug saying,
"We have to get Darius Milhaud
because he meets the deadline."
And, you know, so artistic
concerns at that point are going
out the window because
you've got a fixed deadline
for putting on a show.
And I don't know that, you know,
clearly the "Appalachian
Spring" example is a better model
and even Aaron Copland couldn't
meet the initial deadline
because the debut was
about a year late,
I think, from what they thought.
>> David H. Plylar: This is a--
I mean, speaking from experience,
this is a very common thing
for composers to be late
on these types of things.
So I don't-- while we, you know,
we talk about Chavez not being able
to get it done, I don't-- I can
kind of understand a little bit.
>> Aaron Sherber: Copland said, it
was part for the course for Chavez--
>> David H. Plylar: Oh,
with the-- well, sure.
>> Aaron Sherber He was frequently
late and incommunicado, so.
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
Well the-- And then you
have people like Milhaud
who did have the reputation
of just writing.
So, prolifically and
easily and he did.
He actually produced it so
quickly that it was no problems.
>> Aaron Sherber: You talked about
the mechanics of all of this.
And I'll add two things to sort
of bracket this discussion.
So, what we're talking
about this period is--
particularly in the '40s with
Martha Graham as she was working
with better known composers the way
she worked as David indicated was
to send this scenario,
description of the dance
and the composer would
work from that
and then send the dance
back previously.
So, one of the great things about
the Martha Graham Dance Company is
that from about 1935
until 1975, all--
I think, all but three of Martha's
new dances used commissioned music,
new music and almost
all new American music.
It's a really unmatched
record of support
for American contemporary composers.
And so, from my point, that's
a wonderful thing to work with.
The way she started in 1935
with commission music was her
music director Louis Horst,
who was a very influential figure
in not only modern dance music
but modern dance as well.
If you go back to Graham's mentors,
Ruth St. Denis and Ted Shawn,
and people-- other people
like Isadora Duncan,
turn of the century modern dance,
the way they made a dance was
they'd find something nice
by Satie [assumed spelling]
that has some full orientalism
and they'd add some
scarves and some incense
and they would decorate the music
and that was their idea, I mean,
I'm simplifying a bit, but
they would decorate the music.
And Horst was one of the
first people to say, "Yeah,
if you want to be taken seriously,
if you want this modern dance
to be taken seriously,
the choreographer's
ideas have to come first.
And you can't go find existing
music and fit your ideas it.
You have to have your ideas and the
music will fit it like a frame."
And so from 1935 until that 1940,
41, a lot of people who wrote scores
for Graham were friends with
Louis who would come in and work
with Graham in the studio
so that while she was
improvising movement phrases,
they would be improvising at the
piano and finding things that fit.
And then, when she had the
final shape for her dance,
then the composer would
find the final shape.
But that false apart in the '40s
because Aaron Copland isn't going
to sit in the studio for weeks
on end while Graham improvises.
But-- So, and the other
thing to bracket that though,
with all this long distance
and the correspondence,
Martha Graham was doing a pair
of pieces, one called "Sarabande"
and one called "Deep Song" and
the composer was Henry Cowell.
Graham and Louis Horst
that time were working
at Bennington-- Bennington, I think?
Was it Bennington or
was it Connecticut?
I forgot. They were
somewhere over New England.
And Henry Cowell was in California
and not only was he in California,
he was in prison in California.
He was in San Quentin and still
wanted to follow the commission.
Do you-- have you heard this?
>> Libby Smigel: No.
This is fascinating.
>> Aaron Sherber: So, Horst and
Graham flew out to California
to meet him and-- in San Quentin,
Martha Graham demonstrates some
of what she has in mind
for the dance and talks him
about what her ideas are and how
this all work and then they leave.
And what Cowell does is he-- a while
later, sends back east a packet
of music, a series of, I think,
13 or 14 melodic fragments and 8
or 9 percussion fragments
to join them.
And he says, "I wrote these in
the style of what you showed me.
Now that you know what
he finish dance is,
you should arrange them the way you
want them and put them in the order
that matches what Martha did."
>> David H. Plylar: That's great.
>> Aaron Sherber: And they did it.
Yeah.
>> David H. Plylar: Wow.
>> Aaron Sherber: Yeah.
So, that's the extreme of
not being in the same place.
>> David H. Plylar: Well, you know,
I'm speaking to that relationship
and it's amazing that there they
had an identified relationship
that worked well.
One thing I want to mention before
we kind of shift back to 1944
through '46 and beyond, is just
the Library's earliest commission--
dance-related commission, I'm kind
of counting them as dance related
if there was a component that
came out of it and that would be
"Apollo Musage`te" Stravinsky.
And Adolf Bolm was the original
choreographer and the dancer
who was involved in this
has a bit of a strange story
and that his choreography is not
the one that is known for that work.
In fact, it was Balanchine,
I think, whose choreography
and also renamed it as "Apollo".
And that that became the
way that we know that work
that was originated
here and performed here.
But that's kind of a case where
somewhere in that process,
something-- I don't know the
full story, so I'm not sure how
that happened, but
something went array.
>> Libby Smigel: So, anyone who
wants to look at a research topic
that would be publishable.
This sounds like one?
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah, right?
>> Libby Smigel: But
that's interesting too
because it was Ruth Page,
who later was, you know,
ascending as a Chicago-based dancer.
And Adolf Bolm also
was Chicago based.
And I've sort of wondered, you
know, whether just their location,
when dance as a center in New
York seem to be so important that,
you know, the ones
on the sort of edges,
because San Francisco
had its stars too,
which we just don't
know as much about.
So, there are lots of things
to consider, but that's--
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
>> Libby Smigel -- that's a
really good question because--
>> David H. Plylar
That's-- that also--
speaking of that same thought was
actually articulated by Dakin Hearts
at our Noguchi lecture
just the other night.
And he used images of these costumes
that Noguchi had designed for Page.
But felt that, again, that part
of her regionalism was part
of the reason that she wasn't
able to take off with--
anyway, that's a bit
of in a side, but OK.
But going back to maybe this, just
looking a bit more at this process
of creation, the notion
of a scenario and what
that tells a composer is
an interesting one to me
because that does not strike me
as terribly specific in terms
of what kind of information
is being conveyed.
>> Aaron Sherber: Well, you need
you to look at the scenarios
that Graham sent Copland.
>> David H. Plylar: Well, maybe
you can speak to that a bit.
>> Libby Smigel: Well, she
started out with some curious ideas
that might not be seemingly
a hit now.
There was a speaking character
in Native American that she had.
She had-- It was much more episodic.
So for example, there was an episode
of John Brown's uprising
at Harpers Ferry.
There was a lot.
It could have been, you
know, a three-hour melodrama.
And, you know, Copland would
write back and go, "Well,
this is an interesting part."
And kind of give her a feedback
and she'd do another iteration
and kind of move along.
In fact, I think she tried out
the "Medea" idea as well with him.
And he was like that's--
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
Before they got to
"House of Victory".
>> Libby Smigel: Exactly.
>> Aaron Sherber: She was very
interested in "Medea", but--
>> Libby Smigel: In "Medea" and
he said, "That's really not me.
That's not a good fit."
>> Aaron Sherber: She sent
him "Medea" in New England.
So, it wasn't quite the
"Medea" that we got that far.
>> Libby Smigel: No.
No. Not at all.
But at any rate, she sort
of would try out these ideas
and I am a believer that
whether you're writing
or choreographing a
good editor, when you--
trust is a great thing to have and I
think this is where we see a really,
sort of a trustworthy relationship,
where she was getting back frank
but very helpful feedback.
And, you know, that played to both
of their strengths ultimately.
>> David H. Plylar Please go ahead.
>> Aaron Sherber: But the--
Then the interesting--
the end to that though is, first of
all, if you look at the last script
that she sent him and you
sit there with the score,
you can through almost line by line
and see what Copland was doing.
Copland, at this point,
he was working on--
working a story out in Hollywood.
He was doing film scores.
And so, he was basically scoring the
final scenario that Graham sent him.
And then, what's really interesting,
not only did Copland not know the
name of the ballet until they got
down here, he didn't even see it.
He didn't see nothing of the
ballet until the dress rehearsal,
the night before it opened.
And what he didn't know was
when Graham got the score back,
it took her in different directions.
And so, things that she described
in great detail to Copland,
she decided to do something
totally different with that music.
He was OK with that though.
>> David H. Plylar: I
think that your mentioning
of film scoring though is an
important one just to bear
in my mind in terms of that level
of trust that one must have,
at some point, in terms of one's
ability to realize either something
as scripted or a scenario that
is suggested versus the types
of demands that he was becoming
used to in terms of the--
meaning how you literally deal with
time and use those as constraints
as opposed to necessarily-- things
that could be a bit more loose
in terms of those timings.
That's for composers.
So especially, if you'd say
chamber music composers.
Time is an issue but it's not
something that is so much,
something that is prescribed
from on high,
unless you're commissioning
agreements as, you know,
that you have to have
a 23-minute work.
But of course that
never works out anyway.
But those-- Composers
respond very differently
when they're collaborating
with others
or if they're working
on a film score.
So it's just something to bear in
mind that it's a different type of--
way of thinking about it and
some people are able to rise
to that challenge while others are--
don't that we usually don't hear
about those who don't, so that's OK.
>> Aaron Sherber: Well, but that's--
I mean, that's Carlo Chavez, right
I mean, Graham sent him the scenario
and when she finally got the music
back late, she listened to it
and said, "This has nothing
to do with what I sent him.
I can't possibly dance that dance."
And so, she had to makeup
something completely different
to go with that music.
>> David H. Plylar:
Speaking to that, I just--
this kind of shows that I
have a review from the premier
of the Chavez here
that I pulled out.
This is not an advocation of the
content of it, but just rather
to show what's on the issues were.
It says, basically-- let's see.
I'm sorry.
"The work was commissioned
for the Elizabeth Spring Collage
Foundation's festival at the Library
of Congress in 1944, but Carlos
Chavez did not complete the musical
score in time."
So, this is common knowledge
apparently at this point.
"Whether or not he has yet
completed, it would be difficult
to answer from last
night's presentation.
It is utterly without theatrical or
a choreographic quality, pure paper
and ink music and long
stretches of it sound
like so many pages
out of [inaudible]."
That's a bit-- I don't feel
that way about [inaudible],
either like it's not--
he's much malign.
But-- sorry, the part I
wanted to get to you was that,
"Ms. Graham has been able
to make a dance composition
against it is inexplicable.
It's rhythmic plan and it's
phrasing are tenuous in the extreme.
But she has justified them by
the almost constant employment
of a free choreographic
counterpoint,
which not only avoids
a totally static stage
but actually creates
a certain excitement.
What she has done is a miracle of
sheer invention, but invention not
on an intellectual plain, but on the
subjective level of pure intuition."
So, it's kind of an interesting
thing that there was a sense
of disjunction or something like
that that was perceived at that time
but still an appreciation for what
that final product
still ended up being.
So, there you have that.
So, one other-- all
right, let's see.
I think that the-- I'll come
back and mention a few more
of the other commissions
that have been done.
But I think one thing that would be
interesting to hear both of you talk
about a bit more is-- OK.
Let's say that there's this
agreement between choreographer
and composer and things are moving
along and you get to a point,
we'll even kind of gloss over
the stages of piano score
versus having a full score if
it's differently orchestrated.
What about the process of
rehearsal and putting it together?
Maybe you can speak about some
of the challenges that come--
that are maybe unique to dance
and realizing these
types of new projects.
>> Libby Smigel: Well,
from my standpoint, I'm--
what I'm also seeing is that a lot
of people now are using recorded
music and dancers almost get a sense
of even what the spaces
are between those pauses
and it becomes very organic.
And there's something lost,
I think, in terms of the sort
of performative presence
of really being able
to commune with the accompaniment.
Which isn't to say that they aren't
wonderful because oftentimes,
they can't afford anything but
recorded music but, you know,
I think we all even know on
our little iPhones, you know,
that we can even know how much space
it is before our next favorite song
kicks in, what that time is.
We get to know that and it
becomes then maybe more mechanical.
And a number of choreographers such
as Mark Morris who likes to perform
with the live music and tours
with, usually, with his own group
if he can, is that he has them
record many different versions
and just pop these in as a surprise.
So, you know, tonight,
we're using this one.
And so, they get that sense that
it's still the same orchestration,
it's the same set of musicians,
but that human thing of, you know,
never being able to do it exactly
the same a second time means
that they have to be listening.
And he really does respect
the musicality of dancers.
And that's what he's also looking
for when he's even
choosing his dancers.
But, you know, then we have Merce
Cunningham, who works completely
against that in a sense
that, you know,
he doesn't let the dancers
do rehears to a, sort of,
mechanical stopwatch-driven time.
And that music is going to come--
or accompaniment or sound score
or whatever it is that Merce
Cunningham would've commissioned
that was made separately from
the dance and would be imposed
at the same time for
the dress rehearsal.
And then, he's hoping that
that internal ability to move
and to hear it within yourself,
irrespective of what's happening
on the outside or the
coughs in the audience,
that it's going to be the same.
And so, he's actually going for
something that's replicable,
which is an interesting,
very different aesthetic.
>> Aaron Sherber: That's
interesting.
So, two things.
So first of all, I was grinning
when you told the story
about Mark Morris.
I haven't heard that story but
that's been my dream for years.
I mean seriously, because we--
the Martha Graham company,
we perform with orchestra
whenever we can, but it's--
it hasn't been nearly as
much as when I started.
And a lot of it has to do with money
and they've got recordings
and it goes that way.
And I've always thought, you know,
recordings wouldn't be so bad
if you had a few different ones
where you can switch them up.
So I think it's incredible
to hear that.
The other thing with Merce
though is, Merce, I think,
is creating the conditions
for the audience
to have an artistic experience.
So, for him, the-- in my
understanding, the dance
and the music happens simultaneously
but don't really relate other
than the fact that they
may stop and start--
start and stop at the same time.
And for him-- you're right, I mean,
I've seen those dancers rehearse
with the timings and
with all that so
that they could do that repeatedly.
And I think what's interesting for
him is how the audience perceive
that interaction of
those two artistic things
happening simultaneously.
But not really interacting.
>> David H. Plylar: One question
about that is, is there--
so saying the early
work of this nature,
was their foreknowledge given
to an audience member or would--
of this sense of lack of
intended interactivity
versus whether they're
actually, you know--
whether that coincides with what
they're actually experiencing?
>> Libby Smigel: When he started
doing that, it was clear that he
and the designer and the
composer would get together
and they would talk about
what is the concept.
So there would be a
concept and then agreed.
And often oftentimes, the
title can give it away.
You've got birds.
You've got island.
You've got points in space.
And, you know, you do see that
there are evocative parts in term--
when you hear the sound score or
you see the costumes as well as the,
you know, whatever creature
movements that he has.
But I do think it's-- it asks
something different, you're right,
of the audience to-- that
it is a different kind
of aesthetic experience.
And it requires a different kind
of dancer because you almost have
to train relational
phrasing out of you.
It has to come just from the
body to body in space and not,
you know, what you're hearing.
>> David H. Plylar: But from the
standpoint of an audience number,
those relationships, I think,
are constructed in the process
of experiencing the work
for whatever that's worth.
And it might just be, you
know, that that's the end.
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
And I think that's
what he was going for.
I had a long discussion about
this with Beverly Emmons,
wonderful lighting
designer for dance who've--
>> Libby Smigel: She's wonderful.
>> Aaron Sherber: -- who's
worked with Cunningham
and also has worked
with the Graham Company.
But she said some wonderful things
that I never considered
in exactly this vain.
And her opinion was that
Merce wanted the art
to happen in the audience.
He's setting up these conditions,
the interaction of the dance
and the music and the lighting
and whether he rolled the etching
to get something that
night or whatever.
I mean, because he did
that-- oh yeah, right.
I mean sometimes they
pick, you know, costumes
or light plots depending on roll
of the dice for that evening.
But what-- But Beverly said,
which made a lot of sense to me,
was that he was about then the
audience being able to perceive
that interaction in real time to see
those bits coming together in ways
that they may never have come
together before and may never again.
So, locating the artistic
experience,
the audience is not just
receiving the performance
but in some sense the performance
is happening in the audience,
that artistic experience.
I should definitely say [inaudible].
>> David H. Plylar: This is all--
well maybe bringing it
back to the case were,
like say in "Appalachian Spring"
where the coordination
is fairly clear.
What are some of the
challenges that, again,
now that you've been doing it for so
many years and have that experience,
it's probably not as challenging
as it was when you first started,
but maybe you can speak
to some of those things
because there's the practical
nature of being able to coordinate
between the musicians
that you're directing
and what's happening on stage.
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
And then-- well, there's several
aspects to that and some of it,
I mean, following on what was said
before about live music and sort
of some of the uncertainties that
introduces, first of all, I mean,
we're so grateful to any
presenter in the Library
to be able to have live music.
I'm always reminded Joan
Acocella who writes about dance
for "The New Yorker" and
some wonderful articles.
She said, and I think this is
true, "Dancers move about twice
as interestingly to live music."
And she said, "We can become
used to camp music the way
that we become used to smog
instead of air and we get used
to Spam instead of ham, but that
when you suddenly have
the real thing,
it reminds you what
you've been missing."
That happened to have been a review
of some Martha Graham performances
that didn't mentioned me at all
but it's still my favorite review.
I was never involved in because I
think that's so true what she said.
And following on that-- following
on this idea of interaction,
when I first started in '98,
the dancers I was working
for the first couple of years,
it's a very interesting mix
of fairly new dancers of the company
and some dancers who'd
been there for a long time.
When I was here in 1998,
I mean, Christine Dakin
and Terese Capucilli were my brides.
Janet Eilber was the
pioneering woman
in her last performance
with the company.
So, there was some of that going
on and then there were, you know,
younger kids who've just joined.
The younger kids all
came up to me and saying,
"Are you taking the same tempos
that are on the recording?
Are you following the recording?"
They were very worried about this.
I said, "Well, yeah.
I'll try to."
And Terese and Christine
said, "You know,
as long as what you do is
musical, we'll dance to it."
And they, as performers,
craved that difference.
They didn't want it the same.
They didn't want it predictable.
They wanted it in that range, right.
Something is too slow and
something is too fast,
but there's a range
and there are things.
And so even this afternoon, those
of you who saw the performance,
the first bride solo [humming].
I was a little slow today.
I didn't get the tempo
quite where I wanted at.
And the dancer in that, for
those 2 minutes, you know,
have to find a way to make
those tempos work and find--
and not just rely on
I know it's this step
and this step and this step.
But how do I stretch this a little
How do I give this a little more
weight to fit with that I'm hearing?
And not that I consciously try
to surprise them in that way but,
you know, we're not automatons.
Every performance I do
is slightly different.
I think I have a very
good sense now with most
of these dances about
what that ranges.
Sometimes, I like a side of that
range that's a bit different
from where the recording that
they're used to and that's something
that they've gotten used
to with me over the years.
This is going to be a little
different with orchestra but it is
that process and things
are different
and things happen on stage.
So we had a discussion--
this is a small sample just
about timing and things.
If you were at the
performance this afternoon,
you'll notice that after the
big Medea's dance of vengeance,
which is the big stormy center of
that piece of that Barber piece
and she runs off stage,
there's a big boom
in the orchestra, and
we got a plause.
That almost always happens
when we do it with live music,
not necessarily with tape.
But I had to warn--
there's still a dancer
on stage and the dance continues.
So, I said to the woman
dancing the chorus, I said--
because we haven't done this before.
I said, "If there's
a plause, just wait.
I'm going to wait for you.
Wait for the applause to
die and I'm not going to on
until I see you start to move,"
because with the recording,
she's got to go on.
You can't pause the recording there.
So even just little things like
that, things about working together,
things about knowing what I'm
looking for to pick up a tempo
or to queue the beginning
of a section,
the things that develop over time.
>> David H. Plylar: Sure.
Well, one thing I wanted to
make sure that I mention is
that the three performances
that you're hearing is--
included the premiere or the
world premiere last night
of a new choreography that
was commissioned by the Irving
and Verna Fine Funds in
the Library of Congress
with the Martha Graham Dance
Company and by Pontus Lidberg
and that he was here last night.
Yeah. He was here.
Oh, great.
And-- So, when-- in this
case, it's using the music
of Irving Fine slight changes in
terms of order but not in terms
of substance or, you
know, that much.
So there is a sense of reference
that you had as supposed
to a newly commissioned work.
But actually in terms of how it came
together, was there a difference
with a new work for the
Martha Graham Dance Company?
Was there was a difference
between that
versus one of the reparatory works?
>> Aaron Sherber: Longer
rehearsal period for the dancers,
and we certainly try, I mean, we
commissioned a number of works
since Graham died and we try
to give the choreographer
all the time he needs,
which can be quite a bit.
And for the last several weeks, he
was working generally 3 hours a day
with the dancers to do this.
And even as recently as last
when I went to New York to watch,
some of the dance was not complete
and that's not unusual either
for things to come
together very last minute.
>> David H. Plylar:
Well, I thought for now,
we could actually take some
questions if that's good?
And if you could wait until
a microphone comes to you.
It will be on its way.
>> Thank you.
Hi. My question actually isn't about
the music, it's about the costumes
and I'm curious what happened
to the original costumes?
And any stories about reproducing
them and in particularly the fabric
that these long dresses
that flow so beautifully
in which Martha Graham
loved the image of.
So I thought, Libby
you may know something
about the costume and the fabrics?
>> Libby Smigel: I think, probably,
you know more about
the costume and--
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
So, Graham designed most of the
costumes for most of her dancers
at least until the later years.
And if you talk to our customers,
she was actually very ahead
of her time in the way she used
fabrics and the way she cut
and sewed them to get certain types
of movement out of the fabrics.
And so, obviously,
we've reproduced these--
a lot of these costumes many
times in the intervening decades
and it's always a challenge
to find--
because often, the materials
she use isn't made anymore.
And so to try to find
something that's similar
and will react the similar way when
it's cut and bound a certain way.
You asked about the
original costumes.
So if you've seen, I
think, there are pictures
out here of the premiere, right?
Right. The costumes that
Graham used at the premiere
of "Appalachian Spring"
are not quite the same ones
that we dance with nowadays.
I think they were changed a
few years after the premiere
and it was something that
Graham just decided to change.
And even today, there are a couple
of variations on the
bride's costume.
The young woman this
afternoon wore a lavender one,
the one tonight is wearing peach.
There's a third one I've seen
recently, I can't think what it was,
but those were-- the peach
is more common nowadays.
Graham's original dress was more
of a [inaudible] kind of thing.
You can see it in the photos.
I'm not sure why she's
changed it, but those--
the peach and the lavender
constructed very much the same way.
The plan-- everyone's
costume is very different,
it was very severe in 1944.
The black with a bonnet and very
sort of Scarlet letter for boating
and now it's bit more of
a flowing kind of thing.
But yeah, we do-- we
reproduce the set pieces.
This is brand new "Appalachian
Spring", brand new copy of the
"Appalachian Spring" set.
So, we have--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
Well, the originals-- there are
often two originals for the sets.
So often, Noguchi would have
made a sculptural version
that the Noguchi Foundation has
in their home on Long Island.
And then there would have been,
whatever the first set was
that was made for the
Graham Company.
We still have some of those.
They haven't been tremendously
preserved, but I'll tell you what,
the sets and the costumes
a few years ago
when super storm Sandy hit
New York, we had just moved
in some new studious down the
lower west side of New York
and our basement was flooded and
a lot of stuff was just lost.
It was water-- I mean,
millions of dollars of damage.
Some originals or old
prints, photographs and things
and old costumes and old original
set pieces that Martha had danced
with and a lot of that
was just lost.
And it's been a slow process
to get some of that back.
>> Libby Smigel: But I don't think
that it's unreasonable to think
that these things should
survive 100 years.
You know, they're touring, they're
putting them up in new places
and having to adopt, I mean,
not every "Appalachian Spring" stage
is the size of the Coolidge and--
>> Aaron Sherber: None of them
is the size of the Coolidge.
>> Libby Smigel: Exactly.
And so, you know, you're
having to adopt all the time
and the dancers also, you
know, Martha is the same size
but you get new dancers and--
>> Aaron Sherber: She's
on the smaller one.
>> Libby Smigel: But, you know, the
new dancers come in, the costume,
you're not going to cast according
to who can fit this costume.
So, you often have to make
a new set because your--
the dancers from the 1950's
are a little different sized
than the 1940's.
>> Aaron Sherber: Absolutely.
>> David H. Plylar: Another thing
that Janet Eilber mentioned
last night was that--
one thing to point out is that the
sets are being used all the time
so that the--
>> Libby Smigel: They get more--
>> David H. Plylar: -- dancers
are interacting with them.
So there's actually a
wear and tear factor.
>> Aaron Sherber: Yeah.
>> Yeah. I'd like to go back to the
collaboration issue because to me,
that-- it's so interesting
to look at the different ways
that collaborations
can come together.
And of course, you know, funding
money is always an issue for anyone
in the arts whether you're talking
dance, music, some other kind
of art, funding is always an issue.
My background isn't from the dance
side and we did various projects
that started from different places.
I mean, sometimes it would
start with the choreographer,
sometimes it would start with
the music and then we work
with a composer or someone
arranging the music.
We even did projects where had a
playwright, who would write a play
and then the dancers
would learn the words
and then the composer
would come in after that.
So, could you-- Aaron,
I'm speaking to mostly
because he's the experienced
one here.
Could you comment on, like from
a composer's or conductor's--
composer, David also, what
would be your preference?
Like, how much direction do you want
at the outset before
you start working?
>> Aaron Sherber: Well me, so
from a conductor's point of view,
whether I'm working with an existing
score or a new score, I want to have
as much information as
possible about what's in--
my job as a dance conductor
is to support the dance.
I love the fact that I'm down
in the pit and no one can see me
and it's all about providing that
lift to the dancer so that you all
in the audience can enjoy it.
So, what makes my life
easier is knowing as much
as knowing a brain dump from the
choreographer, what's on his mind?
What are his influences?
What is he hearing in the music
that I should try to go for as well?
And I've done a few premieres
with the Graham Company
with varying degrees of
that kind of interaction.
I had generally little
less interaction
with Pontus on this dance.
We corresponded early on
as he was trying to figure
out which Irving Fine
pieces he wanted to use.
So I sent him some
thoughts about some
of the ones that he was looking at.
Just, again, from my point of
view information for him to use.
And I went up last week to watch
some rehearsals but even then,
he seemed hesitant
to tell me too much.
Maybe that's his way of handling
that working relationship.
And he kind of gave me some
images about what was going on,
but he was very hesitant
to describe a through line
to the dance or to give it a plot.
So, I'm working with little
snippets of things I hear and trying
to do what I think will
support what he needs.
>> David H. Plylar: Speaking
a little bit to the--
on the compositional
side of things, there--
I would just say this that
every project, I think,
has a different set of rules to
it and they kind of come into play
as you develop the project and it
depends on how people interact.
But one of the challenges, I think,
that in this case with the dancer
and the choreographer-- or
sorry, with the choreographer
and the composer being involved
is that the composition, at least,
some types of composition tend
to be more of a solitary endeavor
when it comes to the actual
production of the work,
while there is a bit more
of a social component
to the choreographic
one, where you're working
with the dancers and having that.
And so, it really does have to
be some sort of a coming to terms
with each other and
that just all depends
on the nature of the project.
And I know the people who have
frequent collaborations well,
they might-- it might be that they
work out a pattern of how they work,
but oftentimes they-- each
project demands different types
of ways of collaborating.
So that's just probably just one
thing to throw out about that.
Another. Oh, we have
one here in the middle.
>> Who's going to go first?
>> David H. Plylar: Go ahead.
>> OK. I'm just curious about
how the company has changed
over the year as the
world has changed in terms
of its approached choreography.
>> Aaron Sherber: One of my least
favorite things about the reviews
that we often get, and I'd love
to hear your perspective
on this historically.
A lot of our reviews say,
"Boy, everything was great.
I had a great time but boy, is
that Graham choreography dated."
That is my personal pet peeve
because it is absolutely true
that I don't think there are any
choreographers working today working
in the style of Graham,
whether you're talking
about the specific movements
or whether you're talking
about her sense of theater.
It's a very overtly dramatic style.
It's a very narrative style in
most cases that it's very hard
on your sleeve style that I think
it's just not very [inaudible]
and that's very true.
But nobody is running the
same way Beethoven wrote.
And we don't call his music dated.
The ballet steps have been around
for how long and we don't say,
"Well, I was in Balanchine,
but boy, does that look dated?"
>> Libby Smigel: Or play.
Same thing with plays.
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
>> Libby Smigel: It's what you're
doing with them rather than--
>> Aaron Sherber: Right.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Aaron Sherber: Yes.
Yes. I think there's a
real belief in the company
and I believe this
too that we're not--
we don't want to perform the pieces
the way they are performed in 1944.
We have to take these
pieces and relate them
to a contemporary audience.
So, yes these dances where
made up 50 years ago and yes,
it's a very different kind
of story telling that we have
to honor the spirit of that.
We don't want to change
what Martha did
but at the same time we're
performing it in the year 2016
for the audience that
have seen decades worth
of stuff in the interim.
And it-- But to me, it's
not an unusual thing.
It's the same challenge
that, for example,
an orchestra faces playing Beethoven
or playing Copland
or playing Debussy.
You don't play it the
way you did back then.
You take some lessons form back
then, you're presenting a style
but you can't have that, you
know, one foot in both camps.
But at the same time, so
as we've done commissions
since Graham's death, there has
been a very active discussion
about what kind of choreographers
to work with to extend that legacy.
Are we looking for choreographers
who are consciously working
in something related to
Graham's style in some way?
Or are we looking for just good
choreographers and different leaders
of the company who have
had different viewpoints
on that sort of thing?
But there's very much a sense,
and I know this is something
Janet thinks a lot about is how
to invigorate these works and make
them not seem like museum pieces
and make them really just speak
to you in a certain senses as,
you know, as a performer
or as an audience member,
if I'm watching something,
I don't care how old it is.
I don't care when it was written.
It's all interesting.
But what I care is does it move me?
>> Libby Smigel: Also,
I think dance people
when they are reviving an
older work, they often talk
about reconstruction which is
possibly the least creative sort
of word to use.
And instead of finding the
life that's within that piece
that made it iconic to start
with, they're, you know,
they're sort of thinking about
where the feet were instead
of going how do we get the people to
embody the intention of this work?
I mean the emotions, the ideals
of an "Appalachian Spring",
of the "Cave of the Heart" are, you
know, as fresh today as they were,
you know, a thousand years ago
when on the Greekness [phonetic].
And these, you know, people get
angry, they're jealous, they're,
you know, delighted when
they're married, they're in love.
These are not new things.
So how do you take the way that
choreographer or the playwright
or the person writing music
or any of those or the opera
and make it new for, you know,
do what Yo-Yo Ma did for Bach
in the 21st century audience,
you know, that made it something
that Americans got excited about.
And, you know, so I think
that we have to rethink that.
We have "Revelations", we
have "Appalachian Spring".
I would say those are two
major American iconic dances.
And, you know, why do we-- we're
reviving Broadway, you know,
"Guys and Dolls" that
seems David to me.
And yet we find--
>> David H. Plylar:
Oh, that's great.
>> Libby Smigel: Well, it's great.
It's great stuff but it's still
a lot of the lyrics and stuff
to me seem David in
the 21st century.
It's still fun to go and see.
And so, the challenge for us is
to find similar ways to revive,
re-stage, re-imagine dance that
has been really important to us
so that we can experience it again.
And I have to say, I think
what Janet and you are doing--
I've seen "Appalachian
Spring" a lot.
I've seen, you know, I'm not young.
And I think this was one of the
most delightfully fresh, exciting,
productions that I can remember
of the "Appalachian Spring".
So you're to be commended
and Janet as well.
>> Aaron Sherber: And
it's very interesting.
This gets to the historical point as
well and gets to what we're saying
about costumes and
different dancers and things.
They are always different dancers
coming into these roles, right?
Now, one thing-- So when I
started with the company,
the brides I was working
with were Terese Capucilli
and Christine Daking who were two
of the senior dancers
in the Graham world.
They've been there since
the late '70s, I think.
And they brought such a wealth of
experience to that role that I got
to learn from working with them.
And then I've worked with
another bride [inaudible]
who is also a senior dancer in the
company in about 10, 12 years ago.
A young dancer named Blakeley
White-McGuire took on the role
and it was a revelation for me
because she was 25 and she wasn't 40
and she was-- and Graham was 50
when the dance was premiered.
>> Libby Smigel: Was
recording, yeah.
>> Aaron Sherber: But suddenly,
I was seeing things just
because she was younger and fresher,
it's a whole different bride
and I started hearing her music in
a whole different way and trying
to bring something different.
And if you see these performances
today, both brides are very young.
I think the one tonight
seems a little younger
than the one this afternoon but
these both wonderful dancers,
fresh face, young girls will bring a
whole different dramatic perspective
to that role that changes-- so you
know, some of what you're saying
about the immediacy of that, what
we're seeing is some of that.
You're not seeing the most
seasoned Graham technique laid
in performance perhaps, but you're
seeing two young performers who are
in love with what they're doing
and will sell that character
of the bride in tremendous ways.
So that's part of all of this also
is the different dancers come in
and put their stamp on the role.
>> Libby Smigel: And I
think we have to see too
that training has changed.
So, what was really exciting as the
technique was developing in the '30s
and the '40s, then we went
through sort of a period
of anybody can be a dancer
and now we are, you know,
everyone who's a dancer has
to be able to hold their leg
up here because-- so you can be
on "So You Think You Can Dance".
And what we sort of lost
was some of the empathy.
So the technique, the ability
to do certain things, I mean,
it's physically off the charts
as the Olympic competitions
are as well.
Physical training has, you
know, just done amazing things.
But then that interpretive
capacity that really together,
now this is me talking
not the Library or Aaron
or anybody else but, I mean, I
see virtuosity as being some kind
of a combination between
technique and interpretation.
And that means you could even
have a master work, you know,
you see it in opera a lot of times.
But there are certain people
that have extraordinary empathy
with that and bring it to bare.
And that's kind of what, you
know, that's why we keep going
to "Appalachian Spring" or a
"Swan Lake" and we see the--
or "Revelations", you
know, I don't get tired
of that one either, you know.
And you kind of look for what
the new cast is bringing to it.
You see them develop into
it as they make it their own
and that's the part that's
exciting and we need better critics.
>> Aaron Sherber: Yes.
>> Libby Smigel: That can see
those things but they're all
on blogs so we can't take them.
So, I don't know if that will help.
That's the archivist talking
and ringing her hands.
>> David H. Plylar: And
I need to write that down
so that we can keep a
record of those things too.
That's always an interesting thing
to be able to look back as well.
Maybe we have time for
just one more question.
We can also get her-- we can do two.
>> When a commissioning process
starts, does it usually start
with the select a composer and
then they select a choreographer
or vice versa or is there other
pattern or how does that work?
>> David H. Plylar: It
depends very much on the--
we can speak to it in different
ways, but it depends very much
on what institution
is initiating that.
Or if it's coming from an
artist suggestions or--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Libby Smigel: Well, the
initial letters from Mrs. Coolidge
to Erick Hawkins who
had asked in a letter,
"Do you think you could
commission a fine American composer
or a notable composer to
write something for Martha?"
And she wrote back really
consciously to one of the letters
from Mrs. Coolidge's in the
display cabinets here, but she--
and this next one that she
wrote was, "And I don't know
if we could afford a
Copland or a Hindemith."
And in fact, she ended
up doing exactly that.
But yes, it means budget it's,
you know, who's available?
There was a World War II that was
brewing, which was another problem
in terms of getting who was able,
you know, to agree to it and--
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
I think one of the key
things, just to bear in mind
about the entire process,
is that it doesn't work
if the partners are not
excited about working together.
Ultimately, if you have
an institution that wants
to commission composer
X and choreographer Y,
if they are not interested in each
other, that's not-- it's not going--
you're not going to have
something that's worth doing
and it probably will fall apart.
So, there's this kind of dance
that happens where everybody's kind
of probably-- they don't want to say
that they really like this one close
if the other person hates
it, you know, or that.
So this whole process goes about and
eventually things tend to go less
around a particular partner
or things like that and then
of course the greater stature
one has one more weight
that opinion tends to have.
So, they're able to, you know, once
you have a commission with a Copland
or a Hindemith then
you're able to work wisely
with other composers later
too and there's other--
>> Libby Smigel: Doors open.
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
>> Aaron Sherber: I'll add
just one very funny story.
I think about the money
aspect of this.
So Copland, I think,
was paid $500 I think?
>> David H. Plylar: That's right.
>> Aaron Sherber: Is that true?
>> David H. Plylar: Yeah.
>> Aaron Sherber: For
the commission for this.
Which, you know, in the '40s was--
it was not a small amount but
also he could have commanded more
with his stature.
When the Graham Company
performs "Appalachian Spring",
because the music is copyrighted,
we pay a royalty every time
through Boosey, to the
Aaron Copland Fund.
And we also-- and we do it live,
you know, there's also a rental fee
to rent the actual parts and Boosey,
because they understand
the popularity of this work
and because they have a monopoly,
they tend to charge a lot
of money for these things.
I mean, we're talking something
like 3 or $400 per performance
for royalty and another
400 for the parts rental.
We happen to find about a year ago,
I don't know if you know this story.
We find a lot of interesting things
in our archives in our warehouse
that surface after decades.
There was a correspondence
between Martha and Aaron
and we have a letter form Copland
that says, "Well, you know,
I know that money is difficult for
you and I'm so glad that you're able
to have this piece out
there and perform it.
And so, let's just
say between the two
of us $10 a performance
in perpetuity."
[ Laughter ]
So we took the letter to Boosey
and they have their lawyers
look at it very carefully.
And the lawyer said, "Well,
yeah, I guess that's it."
So, we don't get-- we're not getting
money back from them unfortunately.
But now we pay them
$10 of performance.
>> David H. Plylar: I notice they've
been downsized recently, is that--
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Aaron Sherber: OK.
That's like a three-hour discussion
but the short answer is the
composer has his own relationship
with the publisher and the
copyright to the music travels--
and it can be arranged differently.
A commissioned organization
can undertake
to own the rights to these things.
But in general, and certainly
with all the Graham things,
the copyright to the
music travels differently
from the copyright to the dance.
That's the very short answer.
>> David H. Plylar: The difference
is if you have a work for hire,
then the composer gives
up those rights.
But the Library does not do that.
So the composer always retains--
or the creator of whatever work
is always retains those rights
with certain allowances for, say,
broadcasters something like that.
So, I think at this point because
there's a long night ahead,
I'd like to thank our guests,
Aaron Sherber and Libby Smigel
for joining me and having this
very interesting discussion.
So, if you could join
me in thanking them.
>> Libby Smigel: Thank
you for coming.
>> Aaron Sherber: Thanks for coming.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.